[Music]
dave is with us in san antonio hi dave
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey christy thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
right my wife wants to build a house
and i would love to do it for her
however
i'm a bit hesitant due to the cost
and i feel like we're in a great
position
if we kind of stay put we can really
start building wealth
so i told her
we we've gotten to go ahead from our
financial advisor but you know i feel
like if i can get
the dave ramsey blessing to move forward
i might be able to kind of
head that direction
i'm so excited to listen to this call
dave dave answer dave's question for him
i can't wait to hear this
or at least you know i'm not crazy for
doing this
um
you you are crazy for letting dave
ramsey or your financial advisor decide
what happens in your life
what you need is principles in your life
that you use by which you make good
decisions for your life
your financial advisor is not your mama
you don't need to ask his permission
what to do with your freaking money and
the same with me
so you you know you
um
you're looking for somebody to bail you
out because you don't want to tell your
wife no
um
but and the two of you need to sit down
together and decide what is best for
your family i suspect by the way you've
couched this that you've got more than
enough money to do this
it's just you don't want to screw with
it
and you're and so i think the two of you
need to sit down and say okay here's
what happens if we do it here's what
happens if we don't do it and uh this is
not you taking you giving your
granddaughter a stick of candy this is
you and your wife building a house
and so she's not a little girl
she's a woman and so the two of you need
to sit down with a good vote and she
needs to be a grown-up and go you know
i'd love to build a house but it's not
really best for our finances and i don't
i'm going to set that aside or you need
to look at it and go
i don't really want to go through the
hassle of this building the house is a
pain in the butt which by the way it is
but uh but it kind of sounds like it
could be an adventure we got the money
without any doubt
mama really wants it and i don't mind
engaging in this process even though
it's not my favorite thing to do because
it's a gift to my wife and and we've got
the money so somewhere in there is your
right answer and i'm not even going to
ask your situation
i'm going to make you make the decision
i'm not going to give you a blessing
it's not my job my blessing to you is
for you to have the tools to make your
own decisions
and i think you've got them
uh but you guys but what you do need to
do i mean what i am going to
bless you to do is for the two of you to
sit down as two adults
not you taking care of some little girl
that wants a stick of candy at the store
that she this is your wife
and um you know there's times that
sharon wants some things and there's
times that dave wants some things
and maybe the other one doesn't care or
maybe the inconvenience is the other one
it's a little outside my comfort zone
but let's go ahead and go that way
and um
you know then there's times that we're
both in complete agreement and there's
times that one of us just doesn't give a
rip you do whatever you want to do i'm
good with it it doesn't bother me and
obviously it matters to you so go do it
and that's an agreement too but we're
making our own decisions with our money
that is not interfering with our future
and our ability to build wealth
because that then gives us the options
to do the other stuff so it's really
really important that both of you have a
vote well and and have the energy and
care enough both of you by the way dave
to engage in this conversation because
so many people they just want one person
wants to win or one person doesn't even
have the energy to talk about it so they
just let the other person win
and and you're gonna come to the best
decision for your family when you both
engage and keep working through it if
you don't figure it out in the first
conversation have another one and
another one and another one keep working
through it until you guys come to
something that you both feel good about
and it may take some time and effort to
get there but it's me worth it when you
actually both feel feel seen and valued
in that decision